on est cinq affiches de recrutement de
l'armée de terre suite à la mort des 13
militaires en opération mardi dernier
sur l'une d'entre elles on voit des
militaires qui portent un cercueil avec
un slogan je suis tourné vers les autres
et vers mon avenir
et puis sur une autre est dessiné un
cercueil décoré des médailles militaires
et de ce slogan je protège mon pays je
progresse dans ma vie guillaume bernard
à ce que vous êtes charlie ce soir moi
j'ai jamais été charlie je suis désolé
de vous le dire tout en n'étant pas
particulièrement sensible je dirais à
l'islamisme c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire je crois que la liberté
d'expression
elle n'est pas sans limite c'est à dire
que l'apologie de la pédophilie ne fait
pas partie de l'espace je dirais commun
voilà donc je crois qu'il ya des limites
à la liberté d'expression
en revanche et c'était la manière dont
je trouvais mais rassurez vous je vais
vous répondre sur ces questions là la
manière dont la question des caricatures
de mahomet a été traité qui m'a
profondément choqué parce qu'en fait le
problème du point de vue musulman des
caricatures de mahomet c'est le simple
fait qu'ils se soient représentés que le
prophète soit représenté il est des
religions qui n'admettent pas la
représentation même si elles ne sont pas
caricatural et des religions qui
acceptent la représentation est donc
avoir focalisé le sujet sur le fait
qu'elle sait représentation était
caricatural
c'était se tromper complètement d'
analyse de la revendication islamiste
qui interdit la représentation qu'elle
soit ou non caricatural pour ce qui est
de ça moi je trouve qu'il y a tout
simplement je dirais un mauvais goût
alors sincèrement faut-il aller jusqu'à
le fait de considérer que c'est une
atteinte à l'honneur au drapeau je dirai
à la sûreté de l'état sans doute pas
mais considéré qu'il puisse y avoir je
dirais un espace commun dans lequel
effectivement on n'admet pas que ceux
qui sont chargés de la commande hier
delà de la sûreté de l'état de la
défense de la nation ce soit brocardé je
pense qu'effectivement la question se
pose
oui je peux être choqué choqué par ça
pour autant pour autant il ya un pays
les états unis et le premier amendement
ça n'empêche en rien je dirais le
patriotisme et le premier amendement
fonctionne bien donc j'avoue que je
balance un peu entre entre les deux pour
autant moi je ne suis pas comment dire
choquée par l'idée que l'on puisse
limiter la liberté la liberté
d'expression tout n'est pas discutable
tout n'est pas je dirais acceptable
adrien matou est ce que l'heure n'était
pas au respect de la douleur
oui peut-être je sais pas si c'est la
question qui se pose là oui alors après
ceux ci disent ses déficits elle évite
ces caricatures lasson oui oui alors
après on est jeudi
si un journal de caricatures et 1 116
focaliser sur l'idée de ne pas choquer
les gens il y aura pas forcément des
supers caricature chaque semaine je suis
d'accord avec guillaume erner sur le
fait qu'il y ait des limites à la
liberté d'expression mais en france à
mon avis elles sont fixées par la loi
c'est limite donc effectivement la
diffamation l'injure ou le racisme
voilà lancé métis manger du terrorisme
l'antimilitarisme
même quand il est de mauvais goût ne
fait pas partie des limitations prévues
à la liberté d'expression donc voilà
charlet doit toujours été un journal
anti militariste ça ne plaît pas à tout
le monde
charlie hebdo a toujours fait des
caricatures anticlérical parfois très
comment dire acide d'ailleurs
s'attaqueront à toutes les religions
contrairement à ce que certains disent
donc voilà on peut ne pas réguler
évidemment rire en voyant ces
caricatures
on peut trouver ça de mauvais goût mais
en france il n'y a pas de voie là il n'y
a pas de limite à cette liberté
d'expression la judith waintraub entre
provocation liberté d'expression la
limite un peu ténu qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
non allez voter du tout elle est dictée
par la loi effectivement il ya un
certain nombre de choses qui sont
interdites
d'ailleurs trop à mon avis lorsque j'ai
jamais été une fan des lois gayssot
et les vaines
je considère que par exemple on a on a
fait plutôt du bien financièrement à
dieudonné
en utilisant ces lois contre lui je
l'avais dit à l'époque à manuel valls
qui était à l'origine de cette offensive
johnny contre lui on a construit un
culte on l'a permis devant lui a permis
de poser aux martyrs c'est très mauvais
quand quatre qantas et qantas et des
salahi sont nulles et drôle du tout et
c'est effectivement la tradition anti
militariste de charlie dans ce qu'elle a
de pire c'est signer c'est ces gens là
si l'équité qui n'est plus à charles ix
et d'ailleurs et ils ont parfaitement le
droit de le faire et désolé si cette
choc mais c'est comme ça kuchar vers
l'iss était juste de lancer limitée
antimilitarisme wii sera question légale
tout a été dit cela dit quand on les
regarde bien c'est dessins qui sont
d'ailleurs pas des caricatures qui sont
plutôt des dessins d'illustration
ils ont une part de vérité faut quand
même reconnaître quand vous voyez un
soldat avec une tête de mort la mort
fait partie du destin des militaires et
ceux qui s'engagent chaque qu'ils
risquent leur vie
donc je n'y vois pas nécessairement une
offense on peut effectivement considérer
que c'est du mauvais goût mais mais la
réalité est quand même qu'au moment où
vous allez recruter et on sait que
l'armée terre comme toutes les armées du
monde cherche à recruter par des
campagnes séductrice qui offrent de l'
aventure de nouveaux horizons un
dépassement de soi in fine et vous
risquez quand même de finir dans un
cercueil c'est la réalité que vient de
montrer cet accident
ça veut dire progresser dans la vie cc
c'est risquer de mourir je suis pas
choqué c'est mon rêve pour rien c'est
pour ceux qui nous protège c'est
sûrement un manque de reconnaissance
mais c'est la tradition anti militariste
encore une fois vous savez l'armée elle
est dans le débat social
certains veulent s'engager d'autres ne
veulent pas s'engager fort heureusement
on n'est pas dans une période de guerre
ou la conscription est obligatoire pour
moi ça fait partie de ça fait partie
d'un débat qui dans ce cas de figure
peut être contestées encore une fois
parler de mauvais goût mais de fait
oublions jamais que les campagnes de
recrutement sont des campagnes encore
une fois qui vous vendent un mirage un
mirage et quelquefois même avec des
primes et autres on a vu aux états unis
vous savez ces campagnes notamment dans
les populations noires américaines
donc l'armée c'est quelque chose de dur
c'est quelque chose de tragique la
guerre c'est tragique
pardon injuste pour ce qui est de rester
devant des gens qui font ce choix et
notamment les soldats qui ont été tués
au mali
c'est pas les respecter que de dire
qu'il était inconscient et qui sont fait
attraper par des publicités non mais ça
parce que c'est parce que j'ai dit c'est
parce que j'ai y regarder les dessins
les dessins ne les traite pas
inconscient il y a une forme de voile à
vous vous êtes quelqu'un quelque part le
résumé de ses dessins pourrez vous vous
êtes fait avoir
alors mes mais ça fait partie du débat
public cndp a presque déjà dit et pas de
l'avoir été au bout c'est fou parce que
vous n'imaginiez peut-être pas qu'elle
était au moi je ne suis pas choqué par
ce débat guillaume bernard moi je
j'avoue que la question de la liberté
d'action et d'expression c'est vraiment
un sujet qui me qui me passionne et qui
me tient à coeur et c'est là où j'avoue
qu'effectivement je suis dans une
position assez différentes de deux de
mes camarades c'est à dire que moi je
suis choqué que ce soit à la loi pénale
de délimiter le domaine de la liberté
d'expression bien sûr je crois que c'est
le comment dire ce sont des tabous
sociaux c'est c'est la cohérence du
corps social qui doit justement donner
des limites à la liberté d'expression
c'est à dire que d'ailleurs c'est tout
le problème d'une société qui
aujourd'hui se communautarise s'éclate
c'est qu'en fait on va avoir une
juxtaposition de groupes qui chacun va
revendiquer le fait que en fonction de
sa propre conception des choses
eh bien on l'interdît l'expression d'une
autre position est une société qui est
plus unifiée culturellement des limites
d'elle-même sans même qu'il y ait besoin
par la matraque de la loi c'est pour ça
que je suis que j'apprécie le premier
amendement
justement non pas par la matraque de la
loi pénale mais par la la la connivence
par la cohérence du groupe social qui
lie à des limites effectivement à ne pas
passer socialement coutumièrement
tu réellement et non pas par le droit
pénal donc c'est que moi je pense des
limites à la liberté d'expression
mais quelle ces limites ne doivent pas
être peut-être la citation oui non mais
naturellement
est ce que justement le sacré ça
pourrait pas être un domaine garder
duquel on se moque pas de limites
oui est pas par exprès évidemment le
fait de s'attaquer et physiquement et
comment dire et et verbalement et
comment dire et par l'expression a par
exemple un cimetière à une tombe
je dirais à aux morts ça c'est quelque
chose qui alors là pour le coup me
paraît être le je dirais le prince est
un des exemples évidemment d'une limite
d'un tabou qui doit être
consensuellement acceptée par tous oui
alors ceci dit le sacré n'a rien de
consensuel pour le coup parce que alors
là on sera tous d'accord avec guillaume
bernard sur ce sacre est là par contre
je pense que beaucoup de religieux de
toutes obédiences où vous définiront
leur dieu comme sacrée et refuseront
quand je rentre je suis pas je n'aime
pas parler au nom de tous les religieux
mais mais voilà c'est quand même très
compliqué de définir le sacré qui serait
à préserver de toute critique ou le tout
moqueries surtout d'orienter comme la
france qui a érigé le blasphème au rang
d'art alors sur lefigaro.fr on vous
posez la question etes-vous choqué par
la publication de charlie hebdo et vous
êtes majoritaires une petite majorité
56% à nous dire que non vous trouvez que
charlie hebdo n'est pas allé trop loin
merci infiniment de nous avoir suivis et
puis vous souhaite un bon week-end et on
se retrouve lundi
tout